Welcome, students, to our
series on
antimicrobial therapy,
the pharmacology.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
We will begin with applying
our pharmacodynamics
and pharmacokinetics
principles to
antimicrobial therapy.
So this is your
opportunity to take the
general principles that
we learned in the
previous series of
lectures and apply them
to a class of drugs.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to have a chat
about pharmacology.
Individuals and groups
are most welcome.
Here are the
learning objectives.
I am going to go
over these. I want
to make a point
of them. The first
point I wish to make
is that these do
not stand alone.
They are integrated.
So
please try and
conceptualize things, all
of these principles
that we'll be
talking about in the
context of the whole.
So we're going
to talk general
principles about the
antimicrobial drugs.
Mechanisms, mechanisms,
mechanisms. In
the case of
antimicrobials, mechanisms
of resistance are
equally important
to the mechanisms
of action, and the
mechanisms are
related to each other.
Microbicidal and
microbistatic effects,
these are pharmacodynamic
principles.
Effect,
drug concentration,
and effect.
And since we're talking
about microbes that
we would like to
eliminate to kill, we're
talking about inhibitory
effects of the drug.
And as with all
drugs, we're talking
going to be talking
about effectiveness.
I invite you to draw
various graphs that are
models of these behaviors
of the drugs. We
will combine our
pharmacokinetic and
pharmacodynamics concepts,
and this is called the
PK-PD profiles of the
various antimicrobials.
We will be talking
about the area under the
concentration curve
to minimum inhibitory
concentration.
I'll go into
that in more
detail, certainly.
And factors in
clinical selection of
antimicrobial agents.
I'm not asking
you to be a clinician
at this point.
These are basic
pharmacologic principles
for treating patients. I
suggest that you use
whatever resources
you like.
You can use my
word handout.
video lecture,
guided reading questions
if you want to or not.
I do require the practice
questions because
this helps you to apply
your knowledge, helps
you to check your
knowledge, helps you to
think through
pharmacology, and it's
representative of the
questions I ask on the exam.
Here are some
links to help
you if you wish
to use them.
And the list of what you
need to know
and understand.
These are terms,
the language of
pharmacology, the
language of medicine.
I do have the
definitions in the notes
handout, but you can
get them anywhere. So
let's begin
with mechanisms
of antimicrobial action.
Mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
Drug targets, so what
is it the drug is
going to be binding to
to produce its effect?
Microbial molecules
that are essential
components of
biochemical reactions in
the microbes. If we
interrupt essential
pathways, that's
going to kill the
microbe, or at least
suppress its growth.
The effect,
interference with these
physiologic
pathways kills the
microorganisms or
slows their growth.
So if we have a
drug that's going
to slow growth
but not kill, and
many of our
antibiotics do this,
what happens is we
allow the host immune
system to eradicate the
microbes and this is
just fine drugs that
are bacteriostatic,
fungistatic are still going
to be effective because
we're relying on our
host immune system.
Selective
toxicity so this
is the safety
of the drugs
to the human.
Humans in our
case, animals
in the case of
veterinarians.
Selective toxicity.
So toxicity to
the microbe, safe
for the human.
The extent to which
an antimicrobial
agent harms microbial
cells but does
not damage host
cells at therapeutic
concentrations. This
is what determines
the relative safety
of the drugs.
Actually it's a
term that can be
applied to any
pharmacologic therapy.
Mechanisms of
antimicrobial action.
I've indicated here
the takeaways. This is
what you need to
remember from this slide.
Inhibition of biologic
targets, actively
and rapidly growing
organisms are more
susceptible to drug
action than those
in the resting phase
because the drugs
target biologic
molecules in various
pathways or cell
walls or something the
organism needs in
order to survive. So if
the organisms are
growing, they are
synthesizing within
these various pathways.
So this is why
the actively and
rapidly growing
organisms are more
susceptible to drug
action than the
organisms when
they are resting.
we will be talking
about bacteria and
fungi and viruses
and protozoan helmets
over the course of
this year you do not
need to memorize these
at this moment we
will soon be getting
to the various drugs
for the treatment
of bacteria and the
others we will get
to at a later point
so cell wall synthesis
bacteria fungi fungi
need that cell wall
if they don't have the
cell wall they're not
protected from the
environment cell membrane
function we all need
cell membrane function
protein synthesis
folate synthesis
nucleic acid metabolism
various important pathways
that all organisms
need and nucleic acid
DNA and RNA targets.
Viruses are actually
packages of genome.
It's a genome and an
envelope basically.
So the approach is
against various viral
targets. Protozoids are
also one-celled. The
idea is pretty much the
same. And worms, these
are multicellular. So
there are a number of
biologic and physiologic
targets for them.
What's the takeaway?
Inhibition of
biologic targets.
Actively and rapidly
growing organisms
are more susceptible
to the drug action
than those in the
resting phase.
This is an
illustration that will
hopefully help you
visualize various
targets. You don't
need to memorize
this, but it might
be helpful if you
draw your own figures
and label them.
The drug names
here, we will
eventually get
to all of them.
and the antibiotics,
the antibacterial
drugs, we will be
seeing very soon.
The antimicrobials are
categorized, one, by
what type of microbe,
two, by mechanisms
of action, and three, by
spectrums of activity.
So some antimicrobials
are effective
against a few, relative
few, number of organisms,
while others are
effective against a
lot of different
species of organisms. So
narrow spectrum, a few.
Broad spectrum, many.
Why do we care? However,
we need to use
the most selective
drug that produces
the fewest
adverse effects.
So the most active,
selective, safe
drugs that the
organisms are
susceptible to.
That said, there
is a great problem
with resistance
among especially
the bacteria
and the viruses.
This is a figure to
help you visualize
what we're
talking about with
spectrums of activity.
You don't need
to memorize this
at this moment.
You will, I think,
at some point find
understanding of
narrow spectrum
versus broad spectrum
versus in-between
spectrum to be very
helpful to you.
Take, for example,
doxycycline here.
It is effective, at
least theoretically,
against a large
number of organisms.
And it's even going
off the side here
because it's
effective against a
certain protozoa as
well as bacteria.
So we always start by
saying susceptible.
Susceptible organisms.
Isoniazid, you
can see, is
a really narrow spectrum.
It's one organism.
Penicillin here is pretty
narrow spectrum,
et cetera.
Let's talk about
resistance.
This is really
important to know.
I'm going to
write on here, no.
So the mechanism. Well,
bacteria,
especially viruses,
especially the fungi
to some extent,
random events
cause alterations
of the genetic
information in
the microbe. This
is just normal.
When a drug happens
to be present and the
mutations happen to confer
a survival advantage
to the microorganism,
this is just the
process of natural
selection. It's normal.
random events survival
advantage natural
selection now
sometimes random events
in the presence of a
drug do not provide
survival advantage
but it is those
organisms that can
survive in the presence
of drug that would
organisms that
would normally be
susceptible to the drug.
These have now
developed resistance.
Through selection
pressure.
The mutations are not
caused by the
drug per se,
but with increased
exposure to the drug,
this increases the
potential for the organism
to develop mutations
that confer its
survival advantage in
the presence of the drug.
Confer resistance.
So evolution,
natural selection, and
selection pressure.
This is an important
concept to understand
when we're talking
about resistance,
not only to
microbes, but also
to cancers. So,
going back to
microbes, how
does this happen?
Well,
billions of people
take antibiotics.
Antibiotics
are not always
prescribed properly.
Long duration of
antibiotics provides
a long-term selection
pressure for these
microbes to develop
resistance. Let
us not forget
environmental practices.
Use of antibiotics
in animal
feed, not to treat
disease of the
animal, but to
make them fatter.
This is key.
You must know.
Frequent or long
-term use of a
particular drug
increases the risk of
microbial mutations
and produces
resistance to the
drug. I said it before,
you'll hear me
say it many times.
So we have intrinsic
resistance and acquired
resistance. Intrinsic
simply means that a
microorganism that is
exposed to an antimicrobial
drug for the first
time is just naturally
resistant. It has
mechanisms in place
already that prevent
the drug from getting to
its side of action or
producing its effect.
Acquired resistance.
This is what
we are so fearful
of in this world.
This is what we were
talking about with
selection pressure.
Selection pressure
leads to acquired
resistance.
Normally responsive
organisms acquire
spontaneous
random chromosomal
mutations, or they
can actually transfer
resistance genes
to each other.
So that an organism
that may not have
developed its own
resistance mechanisms
to a particular drug
have now acquired
them from another bug.
This is especially
true with bacteria,
and bacteria
cause annoying
diseases, but they can
cause life-threatening,
deadly diseases.
Acquired resistance,
well, both, intrinsic
resistance and acquired
resistance, the
four main mechanisms
are either the drug
doesn't reach its
target because it's
pumped out once it
enters the microbe, or
it just can't get in
in the first place.
The gram-negative
bacteria, which
we'll talk about in
the next lecture,
are structured in such
a way that they have
a membrane that
surrounds them. And they
get their nutrients,
etc., through something
called porins. These
are protein channels.
Well, drugs can get
to these gram-negative
bacteria target sites
through the porins.
So if the bacteria
are able to alter the
porins in such a way
that the drug can't
get through, but they
can still get their
nutrients, then we
now have resistance
by that mechanism.
So the drug does not
reach its target by
these two mechanisms.
The drug can
be inactivated.
The microbe can
develop enzymes that
will, in fact,
inactivate the drug.
The microbe can
alter the drug target
in such a way
that the target no
longer has affinity
for the drug. The
drug won't bind,
and if it doesn't
bind, it won't
produce its effect.
Yet, that target is still
capable of producing
the metabolic function
of the organism,
and therefore the
organism continues to
survive and is resistant
by that mechanisms.
or organisms express
alternative metabolic
pathways. This is not
common, but it exists.
For example,
some bacteria,
many bacteria,
synthesize their own
folic acid. We humans
do not do that. We
get it from our diet.
Now, if the pathway
for manufacturing
folic acid, for a drug
that inhibits this
pathway is altered
such that now the drug
doesn't have any
effect on the pathway
because the organism
developed a different
pathway. That
organism will continue
to survive in the
presence of the drug.
this is just an
illustration to help you
visualize the some
of these mechanisms
that I mentioned the
exclusion barrier
here's an efflux pump
the altered target
an example is
protein synthesis
right here and
enzymatic inactivation
that's indicated
in the figure here.
Okay so how do
we know what drug
we should use
against what bug?
Minimum inhibitory
concentration is frequently
used to determine
the susceptibility
of bacteria
to a particular
antibiotic.
Minimum inhibitory
concentration. I'll show
you a figure of that
in the next slide.
There is also
something called
minimum bactericidal
concentration.
We don't usually
use the MBC,
as you will
see coming up.
For drugs that
kill organisms, The
minimum bactericidal
concentration
is pretty much
the same as the
minimum inhibitory
concentration.
Susceptibility
testing is most
commonly used to
determine the likelihood,
because this
is a lab value,
that a particular
antibiotic, or can be
also used for antifungals,
will be effective
in stopping the
growth of the bacteria
or ****** causing
the infection. So
susceptibility testing
determines probability.
This is a
laboratory value,
but it's very helpful.
On the left-hand
side, this is an
example of a Brass
dilution test.
These three tubes have
bacterial growth in
here. You can see that
it's kind of turbid.
At this point
right here, this
is called the
break point,
the concentration of
drug has been increased
to the point where
it is now clear
broth, indicating the
bacteria are killed.
So the minimum
inhibitory concentration,
the first tube in which
we see the concentration
that produces this
killing effect,
in this example
here, is 2
micrograms per
milliliter.
Minimum inhibitory
concentration,
we will be utilizing
that to help
us determine
efficacy of drugs.
This is a couple
of diffusion
tests. The concept
is the same.
So, let's talk about
pharmacodynamics and
pharmacokinetics of
antimicrobial therapy.
Drugs that kill
microorganisms are sidal,
microbicidal,
bactericidal, fungicidal,
etc. etc.
Drugs that slow
the growth and
replication,
but do not kill
a microbe, are
called static,
microbistatic,
bacteriostatic,
fungistatic, which is
fine for patients who
have a healthy active
immune system once
we slow that gross
see the plateau here
then the immune system
will do the job of
eradication this is
microbial gross up up up
up up drug is added
at this point and for
bacteriostatic drugs
we get that plateau.
For bactericidal drugs,
yeah, we see
growth reduced
to basically nothing.
Which is better? Well,
shouldn't we always
use a bactericidal
drug? Not necessarily.
We have to use the
drug that's going to
actually be effective
against the organism. I
know you're familiar with
these dose
-response curves.
We're going to be using
them to demonstrate
the effective
resistance on the half
-maximal inhibitory
concentration, so
that's IC50, which
is analogous to EC50.
We talked about EC50
in terms of agonists
producing an effect,
and it was measured
by the EC50, the
half-maximal effect.
Well, it's the
inhibitory effect that
we're looking for
with these drugs,
so we call it
the half-maximal
inhibitory concentration.
That's all.
response, concentration,
dose-response curve.
For bugs with
intermediate
resistance, that
simply means it takes
more drug to
produce the effect,
the maximal effect
up here, which is
the maximal kill
effect, let's say.
the originally the
organism was susceptible
to this concentration
EC50 at this
concentration and it
started to develop
resistance to the
point where all
right took a little
more drug so the I
should say IC50 not
EC50 occurs at this
concentration see
the difference here
but we still get
the maximal effect
and in this figure
the organism still
has a little more
resistance takes a
little more drug to
produce the effect
but it's still working
okay well great
intermediate resistance
increase ic50
you can see it's
shifting to the
right higher
concentrations needed
to achieve a
particular effect which
is a decrease in
microbial burden.
But if we're going
to be increasing
the dose, we have
to think about is it
going to be tolerable
to the patient?
Is the toxicity of
the drug going to be
such that it's going
to harm the patient?
If so, even though
the organism has
so-called intermediate
it resistance, we
can't achieve a
high enough dose to
eradicate the organism
or slow its growth.
So let's take a
look at the lower
figure that's
representing resistance.
This would be
the original
susceptibility
curve. The organism
is completely
susceptible.
But over time, it has
produced resistance
mechanisms such
that the Emax
can never be achieved.
We can get some
effect, but it may
not be adequate.
When the organism
is resistant,
because this is
what we want, we
don't want any
organisms hanging out
in here that
haven't been killed,
the organism is
considered to be resistant
to the drug. Please
understand these
basic concepts. This
is a no slide. No.
Know this.
Take out your pen.
Take out a
piece of paper.
Let your hand
send messages up
to your brain
so that you can
truly understand
this concept.
All right,
let's integrate
pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics now.
All of these antibiotics,
antimicrobials,
have something
called PK-PD
profiles as predictors
of efficacy.
I mentioned before
that culture
and sensitivity,
I should say,
determining the minimum
effective concentration
is a predictor, and
now the PKPD profiles
are predictors of
efficacy. Rational
dosing of antimicrobial
therapy depends on
the relationship between
the pharmacokinetic
properties, so we're
thinking about ADMI,
administration and
absorption, distribution,
which are dose and
plasma concentration.
And remember, dose and
plasma concentration
relate to the drug
concentration at the
site of action, which
relates to the effect.
We must also consider
the elimination,
metabolism and excretion,
because that also
will affect the
plasma concentration.
And all of these
features are going to
relate to the duration
of drug action.
Pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics.
Another curve.
Drug goes in here.
Obviously, this
is intravenous.
It achieves some sort
of peak concentration,
which will depend on,
of course, the dose.
This is just one dose
to illustrate the point.
Then we get our
rate of elimination
depending on clearance
and half-life.
And this time
above the minimum
inhibitory
concentration, this
is our pharmacodynamic
concept,
is the area under
the concentration
versus time curve. We
will be applying
this principle
here.
So the PKPD
profile and dosing.
Looking at the
left-hand side in
the darker blue
shading is the
concentration
-dependent killing.
This is a PKPD
profile that's called
concentration
-dependent killing.
What does that mean?
It means the rate
and extent of
bactericidal
activity increase
with increasing
concentrations.
And high peak
levels are more
effective than
low peak levels.
The rate and extent
of killing with high
peak levels is greater
than that same drug that
does not achieve those
same peak levels.
Some drugs behave
in this way.
It's just a feature
of the drug.
Let's compare that to
time-dependent killing.
The bactericidal activity
continues as long
as drug concentrations
are greater than the
MIC, the minimum
inhibitory concentration.
High peak
levels are of no
benefit for curing
the infection.
You see the difference
here? We have to keep
those drug levels above
the minimum inhibitory
concentration. So
I am now going to
back up to that other
slide that we just saw.
Please bear with me.
So for concentration
-dependent drugs,
the high peak level
correlates with
the rate and extent
of kill. Well,
for drugs that are
time greater than MIC,
it is the time
above the MIC that
determines the
effectiveness of
the drug. That's
the difference.
While we're on this
slide, I'm going
to talk about post
-antibiotic effect.
post antibiotic
and that's not
explained on
the next slide
post and of course
everything has to
have an acronym in
medicine it seems like
so post antibiotic
effect occurs
for the time frame
that the drug
concentration is
below the MIC.
So that would be this
part of the curve.
For drugs that have
a concentration
-dependent action,
that's this one up here,
it takes a while for
regrowth to occur.
So no regrowth for
a certain amount
of time, for
some time frame.
And that's going to
depend on the drug.
And that depends
probably on the mechanism
of action of the drug.
So this is a post
-antibiotic effect down
here where there is
no growth. And we see
this the longest times
with the concentration
-dependent drugs.
Now, Now, drugs
that are T greater
than MIC tend to
have minimal post
-antibiotic effect. So
for these drugs, if
the concentration
falls down for any
appreciable length
of time, those
organisms are going
to start to regrow.
so what do we need
to do we need to give
doses more frequently
so here and then
another dose and then
another dose no I did
that wrong these drugs
we don't need that
big peak so it's going
to be like this so
the time above the
MIC is so the drug
stays above the MIC
for the maximal amount
of time. That's what
I'm trying to say.
Now, for drugs with
concentration-dependent
effect, we might give
another dose here
and achieve the same
peak. And you see
we have this time
frame here that's okay
because the organisms
are not growing
again. But of course,
we want to give another
dose before they
start growing again
so I'm just going to
recap that this is
concentration dependent
effect so T greater
than MIC would be
more like this other
dose
and another dose
So I think you get
the point, right?
Centration
-dependent killing.
Dosing recommendations
to maximize
success are high
-peak concentrations
and the AUC over a
24-hour period to
the MIC ratio. I'll
describe that in a
moment. For time
-dependent killing,
T greater than MIC
is the one that
correlates with cure,
maintaining the levels
above the MIC for
greater than 50% of
the time, maybe even
90% of the time.
And we can still use
the AUC to MIC ratio
to help determine
dosing, maximize success.
Now, post-antibiotic
effect, PAE, for
concentration-dependent
killing, it is the
greater concentration
above the MIC, so that
high peak, the longer
the post-antibiotic
effect for this group
of drugs. For those
that demonstrate
the time-dependent
killing, the T greater
than MIC PKPD profile,
most antibiotics
have an in vitro PAE
of greater than 1.5,
which is not a lot,
hours,
against susceptible
gram-positive cocci.
But they have a minimal
effect against the
gram-negative bacteria,
which are big, big
problems in terms of
resistance and disease.
Okay, let's
talk about the
AUC to MIC ratio a bit.
Clinical efficacy
correlates with
this ratio.
So this ratio, AUC
to MIC, so area under
the concentration
versus time curve,
divided by the
minimum inhibitory
concentration, will help
determine the dosing.
Dosing.
Do you have to figure
this out yourself?
No. It's in
the literature.
maximizing the total
amount in the body over
time and 24-hour
period is what's almost
always used will
correlate with cure rate
with efficacy AUC dependent
dosing recommendations
and post antibiotic
effect are
provided in drug
monographs for both the
concentration and time
-dependent antimicrobials.
These are the takeaways.
I really strongly
recommend you take
out your pen and a
piece of paper and
allow your fingers
to send information
to your brain and
recreate this table
and the chart on
the previous page.
So let's talk a
little bit about
pharmacokinetics now that
we talked about PKPD.
These are the basic
concepts we learned
about pharmacokinetics
in general.
Obviously the drug has to
get to the
site of action.
It must *********
to the infected
compartment in
a high enough
concentration
to be effective.
And what's going to
determine that? Well,
the properties of the
drug, the physicochemical
properties of the
drug. Is it lipophilic?
Is it hydrophilic?
Is it polar tissue
***********? Is it
going to pass through
the various barriers?
Is it going to pass
into the cerebrospinal
fluid? Is it going
to pass into the
prostate for a prostate
infection? So is it
going to pass through
the blood barriers to
these various organs?
Once it gets to
the organism,
is it going to
be pumped out?
or is it going
to be pumped out
by our own host
p-glycoprotein?
Now some organisms
hide in the host
cells so is the drug
going to be able to
********* into the
intracellular space?
Well polar drugs
are not, hydrophilic
drugs are not,
lipophilic drugs can.
Does the drug need
to ********* into a
vegetation in the
endocardial in the valves?
Because first of
all there are a lot
of microbes in
there so they're not
reproducing very fast
and there are a lot of
other deposits in
there. So it's very
difficult for drugs to
get into that endocardial
vegetation in order to
kill those microbes.
Same thing with
biofilms. Some organisms
will produce this
slime covering, and
the drug has to be
able to ********* it
to be able to get to
the site of action.
So ***********.
Please understand
these concepts.
administration how
are we giving the drug
can the patient take
it ****** at home do it
does it need to be
injected intramuscularly
or IV can the patient
use it topically for
let's say acne for
example so root of
administration is determined
by the location of
the infection how
severe the infection is.
If it's a small
infection on the skin,
something topical might
be enough, but if it's
a serious infection,
even in the skin, the
patient may need to
take it systemically.
How strong is
the patient? Does
the patient have
a strong immune
system? Is the
patient already ill?
How ill is the
patient? How well are
the patient's
organs functioning.
If the drug is
going to be taken
******, is it stable
in stomach acid?
If it's not stable
in stomach acid, it's
going to be broken
down before it
gets to the absorptive
sites in the gut.
Where does it
distribute to? Does
it distribute mostly
in the fluids?
Does it get into
tissue spaces?
What is the extent of
protein binding
in the blood?
Because that will reduce
the amount of free drug.
Most of these
antibiotics generally
have poor
*********** into the
cerebral spinal
fluid, so into the
central nervous
system. However,
if the meninges are
inflamed, the blood
-brain barrier is going
to become leaky, and
more drug will be getting
in. So intravenous
administration of
an antibiotic may
produce adequate
therapeutic levels in cases
like that for the
treatment of meningitis.
How is the drug
excreted? Does it
get metabolized
in the liver? What
is the state of
the liver if so?
Is it excreted
unchanged in the urine?
Now think about this.
If a drug is excreted
unchanged in the urine,
there will be high
concentrations of active
drug in the urine,
and as long as any
infection in the urinary
tract is susceptible
to that drug, the drug
can be useful for
urinary tract infections.
some antimicrobials
are metabolized in
the liver okay so
how do we think about
choosing our antibiotic
well mechanism of
action naturally what
are the what's the
pkpd profile what are
the pharmacokinetics
and pharmacodynamics
of the drug what
is the spectrum of
activity is the organism
going to be susceptible
to that drug?
Is the organism, if
once susceptible,
now resistant?
And what is the
inherent toxicity of the
drug for the host?
The drugs have to be
safe enough for the
host to take them.
Now, with regard to
the patient factors,
is the drug going to
be able to get to the
site of action?
Perhaps it will in some
patients but not in
other patients. What is
the state of the
patient's immune system?
If the immune
system is suppressed
then the bacteriostatic
or fungistatic
drug would not be
the best choice.
What is the state of the
organs of elimination?
How old is the patient?
Because this is
also going to have
an effect on rates of
elimination and also
rates of distribution.
Does the patient
have comorbidities?
Is the patient pregnant?
Is the patient
breastfeeding? If
breastfeeding, is that
antimicrobial going
to be entering the
breast milk and
therefore taken up by
the nursing infant?
does the patient have
any allergies naturally
maybe i should put
that first always
always always ask about
allergies even if i
don't use them in my
case vignettes always
you you in your own
mind ask yourself does
this patient have any
allergies and if it's
a case vignette a
question on an exam
whatever if allergies
is not mentioned then
assume no allergies but
not in a real person
Always, always,
always ask
about allergies
and be specific.
Drug interactions,
of course, and cost.
If the patient
can't afford the
medication, the
patient's not
going to get
the medication.
The concentration of
antibiotic must be
adequate to kill or
prevent growth of the
infective microorganism
while being
tolerable to the host.
This is a key point.
Please also be familiar
with these points.
Because you
will be treating
patients. You
might as well get
used to thinking
about this now.
Goals. We always
must consider the
goals of therapy.
Whatever the therapy
is, whether it's
OMM, whether it's
physical therapy,
whether it's drug
therapy, we must
consider the goals.
So with antimicrobial
therapy, there are
different ways to think
about this. And I put
again here, no, because
you will be treating
patients and you want
to do it properly.
I have described these
on the next slide,
so I'll just quickly
go through here.
This is a timeline
to help you kind of
visualize these various
therapeutic goals.
Preventive treatment,
prophylactic
therapy, preemptive,
empiric, definitive,
suppressive,
and combination.
Speaking of combination,
we want to use one
drug wherever possible.
One,
it's likely to be
safer for the patient.
Two, it's likely to
be more affordable
for the patient and
the healthcare system.
But if combination
therapy is needed, do not
be afraid to use it
because you're thinking
about cost. you must
give the best therapy
for the patient so why
would we use combinations
to so they work
together for a greater
effect or to broaden
the spectrum if it's
needed unfortunately
there is no antimicrobial
that will have a broad
enough spectrum on
its own especially when
thinking about empiric
therapy. So let's
look at all of these.
So prevention.
Prophylactic therapy
to prevent an
infection in people
at high risk. We
don't use it for
people at low risk.
The likelihood of
someone at low risk for
infection to get the
infection isn't worth
the exposing the patient
to the antimicrobial.
So when would we use
preventive therapy?
Well, if a patient's
having surgery and
we want to prevent
introduction of infection
into the surgical
wound, if a patient
has immunosuppression
and will not have the
full complement of
the immune response to
protect them from a
potential infection.
And an endocarditis.
This is for
certain patients who
are at high risk for
developing endocarditis
from a dental
surgery, then
prophylactic therapy
with antibiotic
may be appropriate.
Now, preemptive.
If a patient is
likely to be exposed
to a dangerous
infectious organism,
no, let me restate
that. If the patient is
exposed to a dangerous
infective organism
and should not develop
that infection, is
at high risk for
developing that infection,
then it might be
appropriate to give
preemptive antimicrobial
to prevent that
infection. And a
great example here
is a patient who has
been getting a stem
cell transplant.
Also, you may hear
about that as a bone
marrow transplant.
And they are at high
risk for this virus
that's called
cytomegalovirus. then they can
be given an antimicrobial,
an antiviral,
to prevent the CMV
that's being transplanted
into them from
developing the infection.
Empiric therapy.
You're going
to be seeing this a lot.
use immediate use
of a patient who is
presenting with signs
and symptoms of infection
and that infection
is so serious that
antibiotic therapy cannot
wait for determining
exactly what's
causing the infection
so this is an example
of when a broad
spectrum antimicrobial
agent would be used
because we don't know
exactly what's causing
the infection. We have
to cover everything
that's possibly
causing the infection.
And sometimes,
very often,
combination therapy
is used here in
order to broaden
the spectrum.
Definitive therapy.
Well,
now we know what it
is. the information has
come back from a
microbiology lab and says
we have found that
it's this organism
and it is susceptible
to these antibiotics
now it's up to the
clinician the practitioner
to determine what
or what antibiotic
would be best to treat
the patient with this
infection And we aim
for a narrow-spectrum
antimicrobial agent
that is specifically
directed at that organism.
So it's definitive
therapy. It's a well
-defined organism.
And we use narrow
-spectrum because
it's less likely,
well, it's
associated with fewer
adverse effects.
Suppressive
therapy. This is for
immunosuppressed
individuals. They've
been treated for
some infection.
The infection will
not completely
go away. It's
just suppressed.
And so suppressive
therapy is used to prevent
the infection from
becoming full-blown.
And combination,
I mentioned that
here with the empiric
therapy to for
the synergy. In
other words, the two
together is
greater, produces a
greater effect than
either one alone.
And that's it. So please
understand these
various goals.
Goals, always know
your goals of therapy.
and finally we'll
talk about antibiotic
stewardship we are
all responsible
for the
appropriate use of
antimicrobials to
improve patient outcomes
reduce microbial
resistance decrease
the spread of
infection caused by
Organisms that are
resistant to many drugs.
Yes, you do need
to understand
about antibiotic
stewardship.
These are
programs, actually.
I would say probably
all United States
hospitals have
stewardship programs that
promote the appropriate
use of antibiotics
and other antimicrobials
to improve patient
outcomes, reduce
microbial resistance,
and decrease the
spread of multidrug
-resistant organisms.
Those are the goals of
antibiotic stewardship
programs. Reduce
antibiotic consumption
and inappropriate
use. This is an
infection caused by a gut
organism as a result
of antibiotic use.
is a secondary infection.
Antibiotics kill
off many of the gut
bugs, but not
clostridioides difficile.
It tends to
overgrow, and it can
cause diarrhea
through death.
Improved patient
outcomes.
Guidelines.
Sticking to the
guidelines. Utilizing
the guidelines.
Reducing adverse
drug events, that's
always a goal with
our therapies.
And decrease or limit
antibiotic resistance.
Fortunately, there
is some data that
demonstrates
that antibiotic
stewardships do do
that to some extent.
Five D's of antibiotic
stewardship. The
right drug, at the right
time, for the right
diagnosis, for the
right duration of time.
And I put in here for
the right patient also.
In summary,
antimicrobial
agents work by
targeting specific
elements in the
biochemical pathways
of pathogens.
Determinants of
success include proper
selection of the
antimicrobial drug. based on
selective toxicity,
spectrums of activity,
laboratory identification
and susceptibility
testing,
dosing that
achieves the proper
concentration at
the site of action,
so PKPED,
knowledge of drug
*********** into the
infected compartment.
It's great when the
microbiology lab comes
back and says, it's
this organism and it's
susceptible to this
drug. Well, if the
drug doesn't get
there, it's not going
to kill the organism.
And, of course,
a dosing schedule
that maximizes
antimicrobial effect.
That's what that
whole thing was with
PK-PD profiles,
AUC to MIC ratio.
A proper dose and
dosing schedule are
chosen by integrating
microbial pharmacokinetics
and pharmacodynamics
information.
expected pharmacokinetics
variability and
the minimum inhibitory
concentration of
the pathogen in the
individual patient.
Goals of therapy
should be
clear. Always,
always, always.
Prophylaxis, preemptive
therapy, empirical
therapy, definitive
therapy should have
treatment goals and
duration of therapy
clearly spelled out
in the beginning based
on proper evidence.
And I see I left off
this list, suppressive
therapy as well.
The general rule is
one drug except in
selected situations
where combination
therapy has been
shown to be superior.
Poor dosing
strategies lead to
catastrophic
outcomes such as drug
resistance, toxicity
to the patients.
Antimicrobial
stewardship practices
promote the proper
use of antimicrobials,
improve patient
outcomes, and
reduce the development
of resistance.
Here is a chart
from the World
Health Organization.
This is a global
problem. Antibiotic
resistance.
Hopefully it'll take
a few minutes to
take a look at this
because we are all
responsible for
antibiotic stewardship
practices and reducing
the risk of resistance.
That whole thing
comes down to patient
care, patient
effectiveness. If we
have antibiotics that
work we can treat.
And that concludes
this lecture.